I feel good I feel strong and and every
day I feel a little bit better Al Roker
is on the mend it's good to be home it's
good to see your faces on Monday the
Today Show weatherman called in Via Zoom
to give his co-anchors a health update
after returning home from the hospital
last week listen it's been a tough slog
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna deny this
it's been the hardest one yet and you
know I've had my shirt surgery but uh uh
yeah it gives you a a profound sense of
gratitude
for this outpouring of prayers and
thanks and I'm a very fortunate person
Al was hospitalized last month after a
blood clot in his leg sent clots to his
lungs at the time he wrote on Instagram
that he was fortunate to be getting
terrific Medical Care and on the way to
recovery well this morning we can tell
you that he is doing well well Al
celebrated getting out of the hospital
in time for Thanksgiving a source
previously told E.T he went back to the
hospital just after the holiday all the
while Al was unable to host the
Thanksgiving Day Parade and the
Christmas tree lighting at Rockefeller
Center so when will Al return to the NBC
morning show he says he still has some
healing to do you lose a certain amount
of muscle mass you know for every week
here in the hospital I was in the
hospital for four weeks so you know it's
there's just a certain amount of
weakness that I'm doing physical therapy
every day uh occupational therapy I've
got to just get my strength back but
despite the setbacks Al says he's
feeling good he's going to be a little
bit of a slog but there are a lot of
people uh who have to deal with a lot
more with a lot fewer resources so uh uh
you know I'm very fortunate and very
blessed to be able to have the resources
I've had but this isn't the first time
Alice had to put his health before work
yeah you know I feel good you know we
had a doubt about a to deal with
prostate cancer in 2020 he was diagnosed
with prostate cancer good news is we
caught it early not great news is that
it's a little aggressive so I'm going to
be taking some time off to take care of
this thankfully back in April Al told
E.T he's doing great so far so good and
while Al is currently out of the office
he's there in spirit last week The Today
Show anchors shared their holiday video
card and found a creative way to include
their pal
Jesus
[Music]
and that sweet and supportive Vibe
Echoes what Al told E.T back in 2009. at
the end of the day what's important is
you go home to the people you love and
and you know you you work with the
people that you respect and and that's
all that matters
[Music]
thank you
foreign